hi I'm Ella Morton I'm a senior editor
at outs obscura and there's nothing I
like more on an autumnal afternoon than
hanging out in a graveyard I would
gladly do so alone if I must but today
I'm very lucky to be joined by someone
of like mind
kaitland oh jeez yes I have friends it's
wonderful Caitlyn is a mortician and a
funeral expert and we're just going to
discuss the special nature of this
particular Cemetery we are in Bushwick
Brooklyn this is the most Holy Trinity
cemetery it was founded in 1851 as a
German Catholic graveyard at a time when
bodies were being dug up out of
Manhattan burial grounds and shifted
over to Brooklyn because it was getting
too overcrowded but the main special
thing about this cemetery is that the
gravestones are not made of stone
they're made of metal bah-bah-bah and
that's really cool and we're gonna talk
about how that came to be and what the
consequences have been so first obvious
question why at the headstones metal
why metal originally the idea was really
quite lovely the idea was that everyone
whether you were rich or you were poor
you would get the same style and
material for your headstones either wood
or metal and while this was a lovely
idea what's happened over the last 165
years is that they have crumbled they
have oxidized and it doesn't look quite
the same as it once did as we've been
walking around we've seen the headstones
in various states of disarray some have
crumbled and rusted and so crumpled in
on themselves but they weren't always
like that you'll notice right now there
are these big empty spaces in the
cemetery like where we're sitting they
didn't used to be empty the cemetery
used to be packed to the gills with
wooden headstones metal headstones that
over time and in the elements have
largely rotted away and all of these
wooden and metal headstones and
monuments they all looked brand spanking
new at one point well not only did the
headstones the metal ones look new they
looked like stone they were deceptive
headstones because they painted them
this gray color which ended up looking
like they were made of
deceptive yeah sneaky sneaky German
Catholic so if you came to the cemetery
if you saw it from a distance it would
just look like any other cemetery at the
time well they would look normal
ish so again these were German Catholics
and at the time they had different
iconography than was popular in
Protestant cemetery so Protestant
cemetery us you had a much tamer view of
death we're talking urns and obelisks
where the German Catholics were still
going all out with sparkly crucifixes
and cherubs and lambs so you would come
into a cemetery like this there was a
reporter who did in the late 19th
century and was horrified by all of the
three-foot-tall
crucified tortured Christ's in the
cemetery and he said that this was an
aesthetic failure of the cemetery so it
was just a very different vibe at a
Catholic cemetery than around somewhere
else if you're used to then Christ is
maybe not wouldn't be your first choice
so it's German Catholic that was a
little bit different
what about customs right so since it was
German they would have German verses
that were spelled out on the monuments
my understanding is that when children
died the parents would come and leave
playthings and leave toys at the graves
which is something that parents still do
today in cemeteries if they allow it and
it's custom that I was really fascinated
by apparently the gravedigger would go
into the grave and fill the grave with
the family there and there would be a
call-and-response prayer not with the
priest in the family but the gravedigger
and the family I love that I feel like
grave diggers get overlooked in general
and I like it because it's like a
visceral yeah audience participation
call in response when I say dead you say
my mom yeah me someday I like it
yeah nice memento mori what about the
more dark side what about the depravity
was that crime here there certainly was
crime there you can notice that even now
there's an isolation to the cemetery you
have the subway running overhead it
feels isolated even in this growing
hood the idea of the metal monuments is
supposed to be this a gala terian idea
and it's supposed to be lovely and all
that but it actually led to problems
because metal is so easy to come in
steel and then sell for scrap so we've
talked about how it causes decay and
there's a lot of headstones around the
place that are crumbling but I actually
like the way that that looks I agree it
creates these new sculptural objects
that are beautiful in their own way
there's so many older cemeteries with
granite headstones and granite monuments
that look pretty similar no matter where
you go no matter what you're looking at
in each sculptural object like you said
here at most Holy Trinity is unique in a
way and I think it's beautiful
me too there's beauty in the decay oh
you're after my own so thank you for
spending time with us in the graveyard
today if you're interested in even more
details on these gravestones what
they're made of how they weathered and
crumbled Caitlin made another video on
her Channel ask a mortician so head
there to see it
what do I say no do you say thanks for
what cuz I think you're just too classy
a person Ella
to do a proper YouTube outro you have to
like look at the camera and be like
alright obscure Ian's I need you to
smash that like and subscribe button
I'll see you next week tweet retweet
Facebook Instagram socials we're out all
the socials atlas out there we go
we learned a lot today Wow your training
is complete had one
[Music]